I was I was almost in tears, man,
[music] cuz
>> Yeah. my my granddad, who I loved, um
2 years ago, he died as a [music]
Muslim. Mhm. And uh if Christianity is
true,
then I'll [music] never get to see him
again. You understand?
>> Yeah. My girlfriend, she's a Muslim. I
wanted to marry her. Even though like I
I'm not a Christian, I think I'm not a
Christian yet cuz I still have
questions, but
>> Yeah. [music] I just I just prayed. I
said, "God, if truly Jesus is God, and I
[music] have said all my life he's a
prophet, forgive me. Every time I got to
go and change what I believe, I I have
to like do so much, you [music] know,
gymnastics. And my sheikhs, you know,
they they give me these [__]
answers. [music]
Mhm. I It's When when you see it, you
can't unsee it.
Let's bring up uh Solly. Solly is
my favorite guest that we've been having
lately. Solly, you there, bro?
You've been waiting patiently.
Hello. Can you hear me?
Can you hear me, Logic?
Yeah, hey Logic, how's it going, bro?
How's it going? Pretty good.
Hey Balong, how's it going, bro?
Hey, good. How are you doing?
I'm doing good, man. Nice job. Nice job
on the
on the stream so far. You seem uh very
You seem very educated on these topics,
bro.
Um Muy poquito. Muy poquito. Pero mucho
gracias.
Yeah, man. Uh yeah, Logic, it's been
It's been a turbulent week for me, as
you know.
But, you know, I feel I feel as if now
I've left Islam, you know. And wow.
Yeah, man.
It's It was So like after after our
stream,
uh
I went to do some research into the
similarities between
uh
Joseph Smith and uh and the prophet sala
Allah um
the prophet right?
Mhm. Um
and
you know, I I just searched it on Google
on YouTube and the first person who pops
up was
was David Wood. Now, I hate David Wood,
right? I hate him. I [laughter] swore to
God that I would never watch him. He was
a blasphemer.
But you know
some I just watched it, man. And
>> it was it was disturbing. You know, it
was the
it was disturbing and there was there
was a particular verse
that he quoted that he was laughing at
that got me so mad.
But when I looked at the verse, I was
just like, I mean, it just really
uh
it just really made me upset, but it's
correct. It was the Quran
33:53.
Mhm.
Yeah. [clears throat] It was
I think that was the last straw for me
because Mhm.
>> [clears throat]
>> uh
it just couldn't be it just didn't look
divine anymore. You understand?
>> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
So
>> Wow.
I'm out I'm out of uh
I think I'm a Muslim. I I haven't even
fasted since Monday, you know.
So, yeah. I still I still have I still
have I have some questions cuz
I've also been reading into uh
Christianity. I got so many questions,
man, but
yeah, I'm I'm I'm out. I'm no longer a
>> Praise God.
Praise God, man. Wow, that's uh
one I want to
There's a few things I want to say, bro.
Number one
uh
>> [clears throat]
>> it's tough.
It's tough, bro. It's tough because
you know,
when you wholeheartedly believe
something
and you know, you're in this process
where it's like dang, the evidence is
being brought that while what I've been
believing is actually this isn't this
isn't the truth. It's it's hard. It's
it's not easy to take that. and
to take the next step to have the
integrity and honesty
with yourself, with your soul, with your
spirit and with truth to say I cannot be
a part of this anymore because it's it's
just not the truth. I know it's
uncomfortable, whatever, but I
who cares? I can't be a part of this
anymore.
That that has so much courage, man. So
much courage. It's brave. It's
courageous. And so I want to just give
you your flowers right now for that
move. For
prioritizing truth over familiarity and
comfortability.
You know, cuz I man, it broke it it I've
been thinking about you all week, dude.
And I not not I know you know you know
crazy know, but you know, you've been
you've been on my mind and my wife's
mind. We've been thinking about you all
week and like even
>> [clears throat]
>> it's funny. Life came over the other
day.
He came over and we were talking. In the
middle of our conversation, bro, I zoned
out and was just thinking to myself,
man, I wonder what what Sully's doing
right now. I wonder how he's how is he?
I was thinking about you, bro, in the
middle of our conversation.
>> like I it was difficult for me, man.
Like on on Tuesday
Like man, I really I really couldn't get
out of bed because I started having
thoughts, right, that
like Mormonism, right, is it doesn't
have that many members, but Mhm.
if
if the prophet is is not real,
right? And
have
over a billion people, 1.something
billion people, approaching 2 billion
people
following this, Mhm. I I was I was
almost in tears, man, cuz Yeah. my my
granddad, who I loved, um 2 years ago he
died
as a Muslim. Mhm. And uh
if Christianity is true,
then I'll never get to see him again.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Uh so it's just disappointing. My
parents, they're they're not very uh
religious, but they're Muslims. My
girlfriend, she's a Muslim. I wanted to
marry her. Mhm.
>> Like it's really
it's really uh affected so many things.
Yeah. But at the end of at the end of
the day,
when when you see it,
you can't unsee it. You can't unsee it.
Mhm.
You can't unsee it. It's
it's And I, you know, on on Tuesday I
just
even though like I I'm not a Christian,
at least I'm not Christian yet cuz I
still have questions, but I just I just
prayed. I said, "God,
if truly Jesus is God,
and I have said all my life that he's a
prophet, forgive me.
Mhm. If Paul is your messenger and I've
insulted him and I said he's changed
scriptures,
forgive me cuz these things were done in
ignorance."
Yeah. I was reading about the life of
Paul
and you know, I I was upset. I was like,
"This man,
you know, he sacrificed so much."
And uh for me to say
that he corrupted things is is not fair.
Mhm. But
>> [clears throat]
>> I had to say that, you know, for my
religion. I had to make those claims.
Mhm. Uh That's deep.
>> it? It's
it's just that it's
I it's it's so difficult to argue, man.
Like I knew like three times
and every time I was getting rinsed
because like
it's hard, [snorts] bro.
Every time I got to go and change what I
believe. I have to like do so much, you
know, gymnastics,
have to be shakes. And my shakes, you
know, they they give me these [__]
answers.
Like it's it's like
1 1 billion people, bro.
1 billion people.
Like I I've done bad things in my life,
right? I'm not a person with a squeaky
clean record, but
man, being a
like these things that guys like Joseph
Smith do
for the prophet, it's it's way too far
because if Christianity is true
and people are
are following this, this is the height
of evil. I don't even know if
I don't know if God can even forgive
them, right? It's too much.
Yeah, and that and then that's that's
why you see so much passion from, you
know, people like me on the M and M
David even David Wood, who you know, he
you know, he was like, "Man, I hate this
guy." But you you see why we have the
energy towards
Islam and and Mormonism that we do
because of the evil deception and the
practices that it leads people into, the
stuff it advocates for. It's absolutely
evil, man. It's absolutely evil and
people are deceived into this stuff.
They're deceived into Islam, duped into
Mormonism, and to the cults, Jehovah's
Witness, all all these other cults, bro.
People are deceived into them, which is
why we are as passionate and have the
energy that we do cuz we want you guys
to have the true Jesus, the holy, pure,
divine son of God who you will never
have to defend his morals. You'll never
have to defend Christ, bro. You'll never
have to have to stick up for Christ.
Christ's character stands up for his for
his own self. You never have to defend
what he did, anything he does. He is the
example. He is the standard, you know?
And so
we imitate Christ. We try to love like
he does. We He loves absolutely. We fail
in the way that we love. We fail in the
love that we honor each other, that we
honor the needy, that we honor even
those who hate us and our enemies. Jesus
even loved his enemies, prayed for his
enemies. While he's bloodied on the
cross, he said, "Father, forgive them
for they don't know what they're doing."
Right? So, that type of character, that
type of love This is the love
of the God who we serve, who
condescends, who comes down to our level
to reach us because we couldn't reach up
to him.
We were not worthy or capable of
reaching him and meeting his standards,
so he came down to us
to grab us and take us to himself.
That's the God that we serve, brother.
Completely different from anything that
you'll ever see in any in any other
religion, any cult.
But, Logic, I wanted to ask you a
question on like uh
cuz my
issue of my granddad has really been
bugging me. Is there any way
that uh
a Muslim could go to heaven?
Right? Let's say he never heard of the
gospel. Yeah. Right? Is it possible
because my my granddad
uh
I mean, he was aware of Christianity,
but I don't know if it was ever really
preached to.
Yeah, [snorts] so um
I got to be real with you, man. I got to
be real with you. So, Yeah.
The honest truth is that Jesus says that
he's the way, he's the truth, he's the
life. No one comes to the Father except
through him, right?
And so,
Jesus makes it clear that those who deny
him,
he will also deny.
Right? And as sad as that is for our
loved ones who have been deceived and
follow other things and reject the
Christ in their lifetime,
they've rejected they've rejected him.
And if they die rejecting him,
he's good he's gives them what they
wanted. A life an eternity without him,
you know?
Um
If you're If you're If you're ask Well,
go ahead.
Like, this is like this is This is what
really trips me, man, cuz Yeah. he was
he was a good man.
It wasn't his fault, right? You're born
into these things, bro.
Mhm. Right? That's like you
At the end of the day, it's the fault of
of the prophet, right? For starting
this.
Why shh It should be the prophet who
bears the punishment for this. Well, his
punishment is
His punishment [clears throat] is
greater than anyone that follows him,
for sure.
But um it it is also we do have a
responsibility, my brother, as
cuz we are our own individual thinking
human beings, you know? It's like, for
example, um
if I deceived someone into stealing,
right? And they go out and steal,
right? They still committed the sin of
stealing.
My sin is even greater, though, because
I deceived them into stealing and, you
know, misled them into stealing. So,
that'll be on me.
But, they did sin. They did sin and
steal, commit the crime themselves. You
know? So,
in the same way, we are all accountable
for our sin.
And and our rejection of the gospel, our
sin against God, whether, you know, it's
but non-belief or, you know, whatever.
Lying, adultery, lust, whatever it is.
We still have our sin that we have to
be accounted for. You know? So,
>> [clears throat]
>> your grandfather, I don't know I don't
know I don't know him. Obviously, I
don't know every inch of his life. I
don't know if he's
um coming in in encountered the gospel
or not heard of Jesus or not. I'm pretty
I I think would it be safe to say that
he did have some encounters with
Christians and the topic of Jesus and,
you know, stuck with Islam?
Um so, my my parents are
uh originally from Nigeria, right?
So, my my granddad was born during the
time where
Nigeria was still a British colony.
Right? So,
it's it's difficult because like the the
missionaries were instructed
uh kind of like not to preach to Muslims
because they didn't want to uh
start um like revolts. Like, they were
mainly instructed to preach to pagans.
Well, my my my granddad would have known
about Christianity. At least, but he he
may not have fully understood it, but I
just don't know if anyone like preached
to him, right? I doubt anyone did
because of the laws that were in place
at that time. Sure. Okay. So, uh
if that if that is the situation,
um
>> [clears throat]
>> I I was informed that like with like the
the early church would say that it's not
they don't have a position on that
necessarily, but that
you know, God is just.
And so,
um, like it's it's not for us to be able
to make a final decision like oh yeah,
nope, it's over for that dude or
whatever, but
God God is just
in in all situations. And so,
um,
you know, God knowing your your granddad
and the and his situation and
you know, his scenarios and then his and
his encounters,
God will deal with your granddad justly
at the end of the day.
You know?
So,
I don't necessarily have the answer to
that particularly. Because if he wasn't
preached to, if he never heard the
gospel,
well, then it's just simply just relying
on God's justice, you know?
Yeah, man.
Yeah. Yeah, so I can't I can't I can't
necessarily answer that.
Yeah, man, but uh
you know, at the end of the day,
uh God alone knows.
Yeah.
>> You do you do important work.
Uh
your wife does important work. Even even
someone who I who I hate like uh Wood,
Shamoun, all those guys that like at the
end of the day,
I've I've I've kind of like softened on
it because
if you come from the perspective that
this is a this is an evil ideology, then
I can I can understand why they they get
kind of extreme at times. Mhm. Because,
you know, there are there are things in
Islam
that are also extreme. You know, there's
the
the marriage to
to Aisha.
There's the uh
there's many things in the in the
uh
Islamic corpus that are also morally
wrong. So, I can I can get why these
guys are
can be that way. So, you know, bro, keep
you know, keep doing what you're doing.
But, you know, yeah, I still I still got
questions, man.
about Christianity.
So, like I got I got like four or five
main questions, bro. Like So, like this
whole week
I've been
uh I've been looking into the Trinity,
right?
Mhm. Like more and more into the
Trinity. Um
and
every time I try and like understand the
Trinity, it always leads to a heresy.
So, [clears throat] like right now, I'm
kind of like stuck on modalism.
Mhm.
>> Because
Do you wait Like let me ask you, do you
Do you think that uh
Jesus
and the Father are equal?
Yes, they're equal in their essence.
Yes. So, why is Jesus called the Son?
Because he is begotten from the Father.
He comes forth from the Father,
right? And so, that is why he is I
called the Son. That's why he is known
as the Son of the Father.
And so, notice but being the Son of the
Father means that he has the same nature
of his Father, right? So, because the
Father's nature and essence is infinite
and eternal, it's it's divine,
the Son also has the nature of divinity.
He's divine, he's eternal, he's
infinite.
But, so wait, so Jesus
Jesus is all is infinite,
but he died.
Right, so dying doesn't mean that you
cease to exist, Sully.
So, dying is just that your
your your uh you're separating from
you know, it's a separation of body and
soul.
Right? That's all death is and that only
happens if you have a if you have a
physical if you have a body to separate
from.
>> [snorts]
>> So, what Christ did was is that he took
on flesh, right? He took on a human
nature cuz he couldn't he couldn't
experience death in his divine nature.
So, he took on a human nature in which
he can experience death on our behalf
and therefore
have experienced that that phenomenon
where the body and the soul separate,
you know? And so, his soul just goes to
a different realm.
Right? So, it's not he doesn't cease to
exist.
Never. He is he always existed.
But like using that logic, wouldn't all
human beings be immortal cuz we all have
souls?
Well, so when you when you when you're
saying immortal or you you talk about
immortality or or mortality, when you're
talking about mortality, you're talking
about being a able to experience death,
right? You have a physical body that
that
you know, deceases, right? Jesus was
only able to experience death by taking
on a human nature.
Okay? And so um
but even even so like if you talk about
humans, humans don't cease to exist when
they die. You just move to another
another plane, right? You you you
separate from your body.
That's that's what death is. So, when
you talk about mortality, it's it's
having a physical body that can
experience death or not.
Yeah, so logic I think what I'm trying
to ask is is Jesus's human nature equal
to God?
Is his human nature equal to God?
Yeah.
No no, so like what we would say is is
that so the person of Christ
he is equal to the Father
through his divine nature.
Because he and the Father have the same
divine nature, that's where they are
equal.
Right? Jesus takes on a human nature,
right? And it And if you're talking
about via his human nature, he wouldn't
be equal to the Father in that sense.
Right? So
>> So it's two different when you're
talking about Jesus, you always got to
remember
that there's a point in time where it
becomes both and not either or. It's
both and because Jesus has two natures
that he take He has divine nature and he
has a human nature.
Right? So in the human nature, he
submits to the Father. He humbles
himself to the Father, you know? That
that becomes that dynamic. But regarding
his divine essence, his divine nature,
he's equal with the Father.
W- Which is Which is why the Bible says
this. If you um
We go to Philippians 2.
The The Bible breaks this down pretty
good, actually.
We go to Philippians chapter 2. It talks
about having the mindset of humility and
it uses Jesus as an example. All right?
And it's really good. Let me show you
this really quick.
>> [snorts]
>> So Philippians 2,
um
let's see here. This is Paul writing, by
the way.
It says, "Therefore, if there is any
encouragement in Christ,
if there is any consolation of love, if
there is any fellowship of the Spirit,
if any affection and compassion, fulfill
my joy that you think the same way by
maintaining the same love, being united
in spirit, thinking on one purpose,
doing nothing from selfish ambition or
vain glory,
but with humility of mind, regarding one
another as more important than
yourselves." All right? So the context
is having humility, right?
It do you not merely looking out for
your own personal interest, but also for
the interest of others.
Have this way of thinking in yourselves,
which was also in Christ Jesus. So,
Christ also could this humility, this
humble mindset is what Christ had and he
explains how.
Who, although existing in the form of
God,
All right, so he was God, had the nature
of God,
did not regard equality with God a thing
to be grasped, meaning something to hold
on to, something he couldn't let go, but
he had to hold on to that equality. No,
he let that equality go,
right? He set that aside,
right? It says,
so even though he existed in the form of
God, he did not regard equality with God
a thing to be grasped, something to hold
on to,
but emptied himself
by taking the form of a slave, being
made in the likeness of men.
Being found in appearance as a man, he
humbled himself by becoming obedient to
the point of death, even death on a
cross.
All right? So, you see where Jesus
exists in the form of God, he has the
divine nature, he's equal with the
Father via his divine nature,
but he doesn't hold on to that equality,
to that glory, right? To that status. He
lets that go.
To and takes on the form of a servant
and takes on human form,
right? And becomes obedient to the
Father, even to the humiliating death on
a cross.
This is the type of you humble mindset
that Christ had. So, remember when
you're talking about Christ, it's both
and, not either or. He has two natures.
All right, uh
logic. So,
with all this being said, like what's
the issue with modalism? Like why is it
wrong? Yeah, so so Modalism teaches that
Christ and the Father are the same
person. Not just that they have the same
nature and essence, but that they are
the same person. They're one in the same
person. So
basically they're saying Jesus is the
Father and the Holy Spirit is the Father
and is Jesus. Like they're all just one
person, just different modes of God.
Right? Not three distinct persons that
exist coexist together in harmony united
in the essence. They don't So that's why
it's wrong because Christ is clearly not
the Father. He says that, you know, we
clearly see him speak to the Father. He
says the Father sent him. Right? Um, the
Holy Spirit, he says that he is the one
who sends the Holy Spirit from the
Father. So Jesus makes a clear
distinction between himself, the Father,
and the Spirit. Like they're distinct
persons. Right? Jesus says, um, for
example, he says um, according to your
law cuz the Jews were questioning him,
right? They're saying, "Your testimony
is not valid." Right? This is in John
chapter 8. And Jesus says
"Well, according to your law, isn't it
in your law that the testimony of two
witnesses makes a testimony valid?"
Right? Makes a witness valid. He says,
"I testify, I am one who testifies of
myself. I'm one witness.
And the Father is another witness who
bears witness, who testifies of me."
Clearly making the distinction. He's one
witness, the Father is another. So they
can't be the same person. And that's
where Modalism goes wrong.
Does it make sense?
Yeah, man. Yeah.
But uh
also like uh again, another thing is
like uh why exactly uh did Jesus have to
die?
Like Cuz cuz God God is God is
omnipotent uh I'm omnipotent, right?
>> Omnipotent, all powerful, yeah, that's
right. Yeah, so he could have
he could have forgiven the sins of the
world
without the sacrifice.
So Uh no.
He couldn't have. No.
I'll tell you why.
God being all-powerful means that he has
no flaws, has no lack, right? He is
completely sufficient in every way
possible, right?
He's self-sufficient. [clears throat]
That means
that God is also just.
Correct? He's just and he's holy. Would
you agree? Yeah.
So God being perfect means he's
perfectly just and he cannot be unjust.
Right?
So
for example, let me ask you this.
If I robbed a bank,
Yeah.
I got caught, I'm in the courtroom,
judge caught me on camera, man. They see
my handsome face on the camera with the
money bags.
Judge says, man,
"What do [clears throat] you have to say
for yourself?" I say, man, "Judge, I'm
sorry. I repent of what I did. I will
never do this again."
Will the judge let me go?
Will the judge let you go? No.
If he did let me go
because I repented and said I'm sorry,
would he be just?
No. Nope.
So notice,
if even an earthly judge
recognizes justice and has to perform
justice in his judgment when people
break crimes and just because they say
they're sorry and can be can genuinely
be sorry, they can't just let you go
because the crime was committed. The
crime has to be dealt with. It has to be
paid for.
So a just judge cannot just let you go
because you're sincerely sorry.
He has to punish crime. He has to deal
with the sin. He has to deal with the
crime.
So, even more, infinitely more,
is
the just judge of heaven and earth.
God, the almighty God, the holy,
perfect, pure judge of the of the of the
universe.
He is infinitely just.
And so, he can't just sweep sin under
the rug. He can't just sweep our crime
under the rug just because we are
sincerely sorry.
Sin still has to be dealt with. The
crime still has to be dealt with.
And according to what
>> I put it. Before uh before Jesus came,
how were sins forgiven?
Right. So, good question. Before Christ
came, God implemented a system of
substitutionary atonement or sacrificial
atonement.
So, look, for example, if we go to
I had [clears throat] Romans 5 up. Let
me go to Leviticus
17:11.
All right.
Leviticus 17:11.
And this is what This is what uh God
says. He says,
Now, remember, this is Old Testament.
This is Moses' time, right? Yeah.
He says, "For the life of the flesh is
in the blood, and I have given it to you
on the altar to make atonement for your
souls.
For it is the blood that makes atonement
by the life."
So, according to God's system, according
to God's law,
death uh and blood sacrifice, blood
atonement,
is the um way to cover your sin or to
make atonement for your sin.
Now, here's the thing.
The sacrificial lambs, bulls, and oxen,
and you know, all that kind of stuff,
incense burning, that stuff was only
temporary,
which is why they had to do this all the
time. They had to continuously sacrifice
bulls and goats and lambs and stuff.
They had to continuously do this because
that wasn't good enough.
So, what this was all a foreshadowing, a
setup
for what God was going to ultimately do,
the ultimate sacrifice
in himself.
Through the through the son, the
Messiah. And this is what he says here.
Let's go to let's put in Ezekiel.
Ezekiel
16.
Let's do 62 to 63.
Watch this Bible.
Okay? So, that's that. Watch the Ezekiel
16 62 to 63.
Oh, why did it split it up?
Oh, come on.
Uh I didn't push 63.
And my mouse is tripping right now. My
bad, bro.
Just bear with me.
Oh, I said 62.
It was made to appear that I put 63.
All right.
It says, "Thus This is Yahweh speaking.
Thus, I will establish my covenant
I Thus, I will establish my covenant
with you, and you shall know that I am
Yahweh, so that you may remember and be
ashamed and never open your mouth
anymore because of your dishonor
when I have atoned for you for all that
you have done."
declares Yahweh, the Lord Yahweh.
So, you He's saying, "You can't do it.
You can't atone for what you've done.
You can't atone for your sins, but guess
what?
I'm going to do it. I myself am going to
atone for your sins for all that you've
done.
Right? This is all set up and
foreshadowing the ultimate atonement,
the ultimate sacrifice, which God
himself is going to do when he comes in
the flesh in the person of Christ and
give his
>> And
his life, yeah, go ahead. This is This
is the Old Testament. This is Old
Testament, but man, this is Ezekiel
chapter 16. This is Old Testament, way
before way before any Paul or Peter or
Matthew, you know, this is Old Testament
establishment, man.
Yeah, interesting.
Uh yeah, I'm
I'm going to write down this verse. But
a logic, um
there are Now that we got those
questions out of the way, Yeah.
>> there are still two things that have
really prevented me from converting to
Christianity
completely, right? Cuz like now that I'm
out of Islam, obviously
the next
logical step for me was to become a
Christian, cuz it was Christianity which
did bring me out of
of Islam. Yeah.
>> But before I ask those two questions,
like there's something more personal.
Like so if I do become a Christian,
um
my girlfriend
Yeah.
uh
What what what could I What could I do
there?
Teach her the same thing you learned.
The same thing that you learned,
everything that you learned so far, and
then continue to study and learn.
And give her the gospel, bro.
The greatest thing that you can give to
anyone, your girlfriend, your parents,
your
You said you had siblings too that were
Muslim?
Yeah. Yeah? Your siblings? Everybody in
your community, bro. My my Like my
family is not really religious, but I
became more religious in the past like 4
or 5 years, but my family is not really
religious. Like my Even my girlfriend,
she's she's more religious than my
family, but she's still she's still a a
Muslim. Mhm. Right? And
I don't know I don't know. It's it's
if I do become a Christian, what if she
doesn't accept Christianity?
Could I
could I
pretend to be a Muslim?
Cuz I know what no one knows about that.
No one knows like no one in my personal
life knows
that I've kind of become an apostate. So
like everyone still thinks I'm fasting
and stuff. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. So so this is this is the outlook,
brother.
Becoming a Christian is you are making
Jesus Christ the Lord of your life.
Right? You're serving the true God. He
is your Lord.
Your Lord meaning
he is the one in whose hand is your
life.
You serve him above all else. You know?
You please him. You seek the honor and
the pleasure of your Lord rather than
man, rather than your girlfriend,
mother, and father.
You know? It's your Lord that you serve.
Not your girlfriend, not not your
family, not your friends.
And so
um
the best thing that you can do for these
people
is
give them the gospel. And and you do
this in wisdom. You know? You do this in
wisdom and you're not going to beat them
over the head with it. Like like like
how you and I talk, right? Like I didn't
beat you over the head with this stuff.
We took we we spoke. We talked. Right?
Um and it doesn't work out with everyone
all the time. You have to know that. It
it doesn't work out all the time with
everyone, nor does it work out
immediately. You know? Like in our first
it wasn't in our first three, four
conversations it didn't
It's now we're here. This is like
number six for you for you and me,
right? It may take longer for others.
you know?
Um
but you
the best thing you could do is be honest
with them, give them the truth of the
gospel
and gradually
show them why Islam is false. The same
the same way that you came to know.
Right? Or even ask them personally what
makes Islam true to them.
And address those things in particular
to show how those do not do not fit. How
that how those particular things don't
work. Okay? Learn learn more and be in a
position to be able to teach them. Okay?
Um but pretending to be a Muslim
no.
You you So you have to say it openly.
There's no If you're asked
If you're Now, there's no taqiyya. If if
you're asked if you're like you don't
got to go around shouting, "Hey, I'm a
Christian now. I'm a Christian now." You
ain't got to do that. But if you are
asked about your faith, you got to tell
the truth and be honest. You cannot and
you cannot pretend to
you know
serve another god. You can't you can't
do that. There's no We we live in truth.
We walk in truth, brother. And
and in walking in truth and walking for
the Lord, Jesus tells us, man. Matter of
fact, let me
let me just show you what Jesus says
because he
man I'm telling you, man, Jesus answers
everything. He He warns us of this stuff
before we get ourselves into these
situations, I'm telling you. I remember
I showed you where he saw talked about
how many false prophets will come and
deceive a lot of people, how they'll be
successful at it. So he also says
something else. Um
>> [snorts]
>> um
>> [clears throat]
>> uh
What's that verse, guys? I was blanking.
It's in Matthew.
Where
um
mother and father
uh son and daughter
You guys know the verse.
Uh if you deny them for my about you
if you choose them
over him. What's that verse, guys? It's
It's um I'm having a brain fart.
Let me see.
Let's see.
Matthew 10, there it is.
Matthew chapter 10.
Matthew chapter 10. Do you have a
physical Bible yet or do you read the
Bible through the through the internet?
No, I use the Bible app. The Bible app.
That's good. Okay.
All right, Matthew chapter 10.
Jesus warns us of persecution and the
type of persecutions we will face, bro.
Um let's see.
do do do
All right.
Here we go.
So, this is what he says here. We'll
start at verse 32.
Actually,
Yeah, yeah, yeah. We'll start at verse
32.
Therefore, everyone who confesses me
before men,
I will also confess him before my father
who is in heaven.
But whoever denies me before men,
I will also deny him before my father
who is in heaven.
Right?
And so he says, "Do not think that I
have come to bring peace on earth.
I did not come to bring peace, but a
sword." And he's about to clarify what
he means by this. Not war necessarily,
but
the dividing between light and darkness,
truth and falsehood. That's what he came
to divide and split up.
Right? For I came to set a man against
his father, and a daughter against her
mother, and a daughter-in-law against
her mother-in-law. And a man's enemies
will be the members of his own
household.
He who loves father or mother more than
me is not worthy of me.
And he who loves son or daughter more
than me is not worthy of me.
And he who does not take his cross and
follow after me
is not worthy of me.
He who has found his life will lose it.
And he who has lost his life for my sake
will find it.
He [snorts] who receives you receives
me,
and he who receives me receives him who
sent me.
He who receives a prophet in the name of
a prophet shall receive a prophet's
reward, and he who receives a righteous
man in the name of a righteous man shall
receive a righteous man's reward.
Okay?
So,
he says, so he makes it clear,
because of him,
because of his name, because of his
truth and his message,
households will be divided.
Because there will be a households that
will be split
with one side having the truth and the
other side to see uh and darkness,
in falsehood.
Right? One side walking in the light,
that comes to the light, while the
others are in darkness,
walking in darkness freely, and
remaining in darkness, loving the
darkness,
rejecting the light.
So, he warns you, but he lets you know
ahead of time, man, listen,
for
your your concern should not be
man's acceptance of you.
It better not be man's acceptance of
you.
Your your your concern should not be
whether or not
I will lose my friends and family.
Because
whoever loses his life Christ says will
gain it.
Will gain it.
Yeah, man.
Logic look at the end of the day
uh
I'm blessed by my with the kind of
parents I have because
there are people who
they could they could get disowned for
becoming Christians. Yeah. Uh
my parents
are Muslims
but they're not
um
extremists, right? They're
They're kind of like liberal Muslims.
They're liberal Muslims. I'm not really
worried about them. It's just cuz
I I had wanted to marry my girlfriend.
That was really the thing that Mhm. that
was bugging me, right?
But yeah, I'm I'm not so worried about
uh
my family splitting up. My my my parents
would they'd be upset, but they don't
really
uh hate Christians or anything.
They have They're not those kind of
people, but yeah, that was the main
thing that was bugging me, but yeah, if
I if I do become a Christian, then the
first thing I'll I'll
do is I'll sit my girl down and I'll
say, "Hey,
and I'm going to have to be aggressive
with it." Yeah.
>> Cuz
hey, look,
even even if I can't get her to become
uh a Christian, I mean,
I'll still just have to
get her out of Islam. I think if she
leaves Islam, it would be
it would be easier, right? Yeah, you're
absolutely right, brother. The the the
step The And And notice if you watch me,
I always lead with
breaking down the walls of Islam first
and then presenting the gospel. That's
when That's usually when the Muslim is
open to the gospel where all of a sudden
Jesus dying for their sins isn't so hard
to accept anymore or even the Trinity is
it's not so tough of a concept to accept
now that now that Islam is out the way.
It's it's really miraculous what happens
when someone
you know, releases Islam and how open to
the gospel they become. It's it's really
amazing. Same with you. It's the same
thing that happened to you, bro.
So, Yeah, man. Like I don't know. Let's
look at at the end of the day, right?
Uh I I actually went back and watched
some of our old debates. Mhm. When you
when you leave
uh Islam, you're like, "Wow,
I was being kind of illogical here. I
was saying
it was kind of like circular reasoning,
you get me?"
>> Mhm.
Um
yeah, like Christianity like
look at look at what you just showed me
in Ezekiel, right?
>> Mhm. That's before
that's before
uh
like the New Testament even. Yep.
You get what I'm saying? Cuz like the
difference is there's a progression,
right?
There's a kind of a clear progression
because
like when I when I when I was a Muslim,
I I always used to wonder like, "Oh, how
do people leave Islam and become
Christians, right?" Cuz I always felt as
if like from my perspective it was like
imagine you, Roger, becoming a Jew.
Right? Why are you going back to an
older revelation? Like it didn't make
sense to me. Yeah. Right? But like when
you when you look at
Christianity and how it developed from
Judaism,
there's
there's uh a progression. You get what
I'm saying? Yep. Right? It's it's more
grounded in reality. Even if even if you
don't accept uh Christianity because one
of the the things that I was
that that was that was really like last
week or I think it was 2 weeks ago where
I was listening to a podcast or like
something about Bart Ehrman, right? Mhm.
>> And Bart Ehrman said
Oh, Jesus was crucified or something
like that. I was like, wait.
Even the atheists are saying this.
That's why it hasn't changed. It hasn't
changed my my view on the
crucifixion to fit Islam. I have to do a
bunch of mental gymnastics for it, but
I was like, wow. How can Ehrman even say
this like
So, that's that's that's the difference,
right? Even if someone's not a Christian
you have to
take Christianity more seriously as a
world view than
than than than Islam, right? Because the
way like the the the similarities with
Joseph Smith were were too much because
that's not how prophets operate in the
in the Bible. They don't come like like
you can correct me if I'm wrong, right?
But there's no
prophet who says anything about
corruption in the Bible, right? That
says what?
Anything about corruption like corrupted
scripture. No. Yeah, no.
No.
>> [gasps]
>> That's what I'm saying,
right? This whole like corruption thing
it's so Like it doesn't even make sense
why like why would God
uh allow corruption for so long?
It doesn't make sense. And also
the Jews
Whatever you think of the Jews, I know
many Muslims don't like Jews,
uh but whatever you think of the Jews
they at least especially in antiquity
they had
a lot of respect for their book.
They're not going to
You're not going to change things that
easily. Yep.
>> You know what I'm saying? So,
yeah. But, I Yeah, I still wait I'm
wasting time, man. I still got I still
got these things which are keeping me
from becoming a Christian, bro. But, I
just wanted to say that like yeah, like
when you look at Christianity with an
open mind, Mhm. it's way more
plausible than
than the Quran, man. You don't find
Quran 33:53. You don't find Jesus saying
things like this. Mhm. That You don't
find Jesus having multiple wives, right?
Like my My granddad had multiple wives.
I don't even think necessarily that
polygamy is something bad, but
the Quran says four,
and the prophet had nine. Yep.
>> That's the That's the behavior of a
cult, man. Yes.
>> that Smith was doing, too.
>> Exactly, bro.
When you see these things, and I feel
that that's something that
you Christian apologists could even
utilize more.
Mhm. If you draw these comparisons side
by side,
Yeah.
man, it's
Cuz I I was arguing with you about so
many things, but
man, when I
when I heard that, you know, Joseph
Smith had
the same claims
like
a millennia after the prophet, I was
like,
"Wow." Mhm. And and successfully grew a
following.
Yeah, man. Yeah. It's It's the same
thing. It's the It's the same pattern
you'll see with a with the false
prophets. It's the same thing.
You know?
Insane. Well, well, Sully, listen, bro.
>> ask you this. Yeah, yeah, ask ask
whatever you need, bro. I'm I'm here.
I'm chilling, man. I'm I'm here to say
>> Yeah, man. So, like what My My
two or three main things that really
like heating from converting. So, like
my first question is
what what do you think of like young
Earth creationism?
Yeah, so I I don't I don't believe that
the Bible teaches young Earth.
Um
I I don't see where they get that from,
but um you know.
They want to hold that view, they can
have that if they want. You know, it's
not going to put you in hell.
>> No, I'm just I'm just asking you. Like
do you believe the Earth was created in
6,000 years? 6,000 years ago? 6,000
years ago? No. No, I I know I believe
it's definitely longer than that.
Yeah. But
do you believe that the Earth was
created in a certain number of days?
Um
Now, I I I don't know. I I don't know if
it's like
uh you know, 24-hour days or if those
are like periods or if those are like
six periods that it's talking about. So,
I'm not I'm not exactly sure on that,
you know.
Um because those those words can be
interpreted in in different ways and
they're used differently else in other
places in the Bible.
Um so
Yeah.
>> Yeah, man. The reason I'm saying this is
cuz
I I saw like a podcast or something
where a guy was talking. He was saying
that
the creation story in Genesis was
metaphorical, right?
And I I I just I was just like, wait,
hold on.
Right? He said that um it's silly to
believe that
God actually rested after
on the seventh day. And I And I said,
hold on, right? The whole reasoning
behind the Sabbath
is that God did rest on the seventh day.
So, you you you can't just say that, oh,
this is completely metaphorical. I
agree.
>> You get what I'm saying? Yeah, I agree
with you. I don't I don't think that
Genesis 1 is metaphorical. I think that
it's
um a real creation event, you know,
where God is bringing about creation.
Um there are certain things that it's
interesting because there's certain
things there's theories where
uh you know, cuz God is giving commands
for things to come out instead of him
making them, but he's saying, "Let this
come and let this be this and let this
come out and do this." And you know, so
it's it's it's it's interesting, you
know, it's it's deeper than I think the
plain text reads. I think it's a lot
deeper than the surface level. However,
I do believe that it's an actual genuine
event that took place and um
in that seventh day or that seventh
period, whatever that was,
is uh you know, when God ceased his
work. He stopped, you know, his creative
work at that point, you know, to where
that's why the Sabbath day is made holy.
So,
Yeah, like my my main issue with the
with Genesis was the scientific fact
where it says the sun was created before
the earth. Mhm.
And scientifically we know that the
earth was created
No, no, no, pardon me. It says the earth
is created before the sun and we know
scientifically that's impossible.
Yeah.
>> That's one of the things that's been
causing issues for me.
Yeah, so Inspired Philosophy he does
a good video breaking down the Genesis
story, the Genesis 1 narrative, and um
and and [clears throat] breaking down
the deeper
literary elements of Genesis 1 and
better understand it cuz it on the
surface it's it's so much deeper than it
is on
uh like under the plain reading of the
text. So,
check out check out his video on that.
Um
he's texting me right now. Let's see
what he said.
Yeah, he He a he has a playlist, so it's
it's the Genesis 1 chapter 1 through 11
playlist. So, it's Genesis 1 through 11
playlist. I'm inspiring philosophy. You
You go through that and check that stuff
out. And uh I think that that'll be
really good. Give you some good insight.
Yeah, man. Uh the second one was
something I discovered when I was a
Muslim.
When I was trying to prove that the
Bible was corrupted, right? Cuz there
was a time where we spoke to I was
desperate to prove that Daniel 2 was
about Islam, right?
So, I I was kind of upset, right? So, I
went to do
uh more research into the book of
Daniel.
And this was the time where I I was so
happy cuz scholars say that Daniel was
written
in like 160 BC, that it's a forgery.
So, I was using that as an example for
the Bible being corrupted. Uh-huh.
Right? And the scholarly consensus is
that Daniel is uh a forgery.
Right? And Daniel was very theologically
important to the story of Jesus cuz
Jesus does call himself the son of man.
Yeah. All that.
So, wait, are you saying that Daniel is
a forgery cuz it's it's not?
>> That's what That's what the That's what
the scholarly
consensus is. What What scholarly
consensus?
The scholarly consensus is So, Daniel uh
claims to be written during the
Babylonian exile,
right?
>> Yes. Yeah, what When you say scholarly
consensus, like what what scholars are
you are you appealing to that is the
consensus cuz I've never seen that.
>> I don't I don't know. That's what's like
a couple of YouTube videos on. It's not
like a deep scholarly work. It's just
like Yeah. I was watching like a couple
of YouTube videos where they said that
oh, the book of Daniel was a forgery
because it it uh it's too accurate, if
you understand what I'm saying.
It gets If you If you read the book of
Daniel, I think it's like Daniel 8 where
it talks about like a shaggy goat or
like a rough goat and with a large horn,
and that's that's clearly Alexander the
Great. Right? And it splits into four.
That's these are clearly like his the
Diadochi, like his generals. Like it's
way too accurate on like that's what the
guy was saying. Now, for an atheist,
obviously, if something is too accurate,
he's going to say, "Oh, this is
definitely a forgery, right?" But there
are other things in in the book of
Daniel which points to it uh
being not actually written at the time
that it claims, right? Because after the
time of like Antiochus the Fourth,
it stops being accurate. And the
language is also like Aramaic and late
Hebrew, which wouldn't have been used
during the Babylonian uh Babylonian
period.
And like the foreign loan words are
really bothering me. Yeah, but the
Babylonian period.
Yeah, according to the what Why wouldn't
they Why wouldn't they be using Hebrew
in the Babylonian period?
Uh cuz it's like it used a lot of like
Greek loan words.
Cuz like it uh
Yeah, Greek loan words
uh in the book of Daniel. Like I I don't
speak Hebrew, but apparently it uses a
lot of like Greek uh loan words.
>> there is no there is no Greek in the
book of Daniel.
What are they talking about?
>> No, no, it it it's written Hebrew, but
uses Greek loan words that shouldn't be
there at the time of the Babylonian
exile. So, the the
the what I was watching said that oh,
Daniel was written under the uh Sel-
Seleucid Empire, like the
Greek-controlled
uh
>> Just just just really quick because cuz
I I'm not the type that I don't chase
every random claim that like people
make.
Did Was there Was there evidence that
they Like what evidence did they have to
demonstrate that Daniel is late? Daniel
has a Greek in it or uses Greek loan
words or whatever that means.
What What What evidence are they giving?
Because
>> one of the first things he was talking
about
>> have with the scrolls that we have, it's
Hebrew and and Aramaic.
So what are they What What are they
talking about, bro?
Yeah, one of the first evidences, quote
unquote, that he used was
uh that it's too accurate, which is not
evidence for me.
Right? Something being too accurate Like
I believe in prophecy. So if it's
accurate, that just proves it, right?
But the second thing he was talking
about They're coming from a
presupposition that the supernatural is
not possible. Yeah, and I I don't I
don't agree with that, right? So I was
The second thing was he was talking
about linguistic evidence. He was saying
that the Hebrew was using Greek loan
words
that if the person under
Like the the Jews under Babylon had not
really come into contact with Greek
culture yet.
So there would be no way for them to be
using like Greek loan words, and that it
makes starts making historical mistakes
after the rule of Antiochus before, the
guy who kills the guy who kills the pig
on the altar.
Like that's the claim
that the
uh
that the guy was saying He was saying
that oh that Daniel was actually written
during the time of like Antiochus, and
it doesn't There's no
There's no like uh One of the strongest
things he said was that it appears very
late in like the Hebrew canon. There's
no
If it was really written in like the
600s, it should have appeared earlier.
That was This is like the main thing
that's keeping me from doing
>> but what what what evidence is he
bringing up? Cuz I'm just hearing
claims. I'm not hearing any evidence
given, dude. You know what I'm saying?
I'm hearing Yeah, like the linguistic
linguistic evidence.
Yeah, but this is based off of
presupposition like and assumptions.
Like, "Oh, this wouldn't be this if this
is this." and No, like the the pre-
let's let's throw out the let's throw
out the pre- presuppositions.
>> It's just really quick. So, so
um so IP sent me somebody named Benjamin
Newman
who shows that Daniel uses old Persian
loan words
and the language fits with an earlier
period. So, you have scholars that are
arguing against
this this other I guess this other guy
that you're talking on YouTube who tries
to argue that that and IP, you can come
up if you want to if you could explain
this better.
But, you have scholars that are arguing
against
what these other scholars are trying to
say that he's
using language that doesn't belong to an
earlier period. So, I'm just
I IP's here. What's up, IP? You want to
speak to this? Cuz this is interesting.
Oh, yeah, we're talking about Daniel?
Yeah, it's a good book.
Oh, yeah, so there there there yeah,
there are a lot of critical scholars who
do date it to like a later period. Uh
which uh you know, I'm
not just going to dismiss that outright.
Uh but I mean there's a lot of
interesting data that actually shows
that it has actually earlier that's not
been addressed by like Benjamin Nunan.
So, he talks about Greek loan words, but
actually Benjamin Nunan who's a
linguistic scholar, he's very very very
very intelligent. He's gone through
Daniel and he's shown that there's a lot
of old Persian loan words that fit with
a very early time that were not being
used during the Seleucid period. So,
it's like it's like you find an old
English document that says, "Doth thou
protest?" You I I I obviously wasn't
written today unless someone was trying
to mimic it. Uh but we would expect that
to be uh with an earlier English time.
Uh so, there's that. So, there's that
kind of data as well. Uh so, I mean like
yeah, there some of these arguments that
a lot of conservative scholars put out
aren't
ever addressed. And this is like one of
those things that seems to point Daniel
to an earlier period. As for the the
Hebrew and the Aramaic switching, some
scholars have pointed out something
interesting that this might be on
purpose.
So, the book of Daniel starts out with
like Hebrew open
and then it go then it's like in
Aramaic, I believe. And then it's when
you get to Daniel 7, it's still in
Aramaic and the rest is in Hebrew. But
if you divide Daniel into two sections,
you kind of have like two little
structures. Like the first half of
Daniel is Hebrew open, Aramaic.
And then the second half starting Daniel
7 is Aramaic open, rest in Hebrew. It's
It's designed actually the way the
Hebrew and the Aramaic switch. So, yeah,
it's I
I don't think that it's you can say that
everything in Daniel
is like Seleucid period. It What may
have been happening, and this is the the
I'm kind of leaning towards is that it
was compiled at a later point. Like in
the Seleucid period, like there was a
bunch of documents from Daniel that they
had and they're like, "Whoa, this crazy
stuff is happening. Let's get all these
documents we knew from this earlier
prophet in Babylon." And then that's
when they compiled the book. But there's
a lot of huge debates around the dating
of Daniel. It's not all clear-cut as
some like to say.
Yeah, IP, look, is there any like book I
could read on this? Right? Cuz like like
Logic was saying, like a YouTube video
is not enough. I I really want to do my
own research into it. Yeah, there's um
so, there's a guy here on YouTube. His
name is His channel is Sentinel
Apologetics. His name is Rob Row. He has
written an entire commentary on Daniel
that is free.
Uh I I can get you the link here because
I def because he sent it to me as well.
So, if you give me a second, I can drop
it in like the private chat for you.
So, yeah, he's put this entire PDF out
here where he's done his entire
commentary. It's filled with scholarly
quotes.
Very useful. He the first like entire
section is on like reliability of
Daniel. So, if you give me a second,
I'll find that for you and then I will
um
>> [clears throat]
>> you know, you can have that as well.
Cool.
You take your time, man.
>> [clears throat]
>> You try to get that going.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's that's that's quite
interesting. I'll say it like that.
Yeah, this idea that it's it's late. I
mean like you got like
you know, like the other thing to think
about is like for example, take the the
book of Song of Solomon. Like David Carr
for example, notes, you know, that we
have copies of Song of Solomon in the
Dead Sea Scrolls that have been updated
in terms of their language to fit with
that time period. If all we had was that
copy, we would assume that Song of
Solomon was a very late document. So,
often they would update text to fit with
later languages. Like we we we expect
this as well with like the Torah for
example and other documents. Like I
remember reading some scholars in the
book exploring the composition of the
Pentateuch talk about that. Uh so, you
know, like Daniel even
the language fits with the later time
>> things one of the things this guy
was saying was
uh
like earlier earlier Jewish
uh text like Ecclesiasticus
doesn't mention Daniel.
Oh, like Ecclesiastes?
No, Ecclesiasticus like
like it's it's a collection of like
Jewish text talking about like uh
prophets.
And it was written in like 190 or 200 BC
and it doesn't mention Daniel. That's
one of the things he was saying.
Yeah, so you were trying to say that
even if it was written earlier, it there
it couldn't it may have not been
accepted to the Jewish canon yet.
Yeah, that So, yeah, that that's
entirely possible. As I said, I think it
may have been compiled late. So, for
example, uh you know, like you know, I'm
trying to think of a good example here.
So, like um think of the collection of
Paul's letters like Paul wrote various
letters and then we know that the early
church collected them and started
putting them into like like different
like codexes. We got all Paul's letters.
We want to get them all together and put
them in a text. That may have been the
same thing with Daniel is that
you know like they may have collected it
all later point to its own book and you
know there's a great scholar named
Michael Heiser who passed away who said
I always explain this with an analogy. I
call it the holy stapler analogy. Let's
say the prophet Isaiah dies. Okay and
it's like oh [clears throat] he's dead.
What are we going to do? And they get
all his sayings together and they go
anybody got a good stapler? No that's
not what you're going to do. You're
going to ask is anybody here good at
writing? We got to take all of Isaiah's
prophecies and weave them into a
coherent book so it makes sense. And
that's what's going on and if the Holy
Spirit can inspire Isaiah he can also
help lead the writers of the tradents to
make the book coherent and pass it
along. So that that's what's sort of
going on here is like Daniel speaks he
gives these prophecies his writings are
collected and then at a later point
there it's compiled into a coherent book
so the later people can understand it.
Yeah but I'd be like the atheists are
they're always going to be skeptical
about it cuz like like I said it's so
it's so accurate that
if like there's there's no logical
explanation for it.
Right from an atheist perspective. You
get what I'm saying like
like if you just read Daniel it doesn't
seem that miraculous but when you have
the historical context and you actually
read
the like explanation of what
the author is talking about it becomes
kind of like scary. Right you have like
perfect predictions right?
The the main issue is that like it stops
getting accurate after Antiochus the
fourth.
Yeah there there's a lot of stuff and I
I just put the link to Rob two two links
to Rob Rose commentary. He goes through
a lot of stuff.
>> out, man. Yeah, I mean like so I mean
like there's a whole there's a whole lot
of cultural context in there. It Make
sure one of those links works. The
second one you might need to request
access and I'll just let him know and
he'll send it to you. What what's his
what's his channel again? Sentinel
Apologetics.
Sentinel Apologetics. All right, man.
I'll definitely be checking this out,
bro. Yeah, he cites Benjamin Noonan
there a lot. So that that that's good to
get some good information on Daniel.
He's got some good commentary. He
includes a ton of quotes like How how do
you spell how do you spell
Benjamin's surname?
O'Noonan. So yeah, it's not Newman. It's
it I got it wrong when I first said it
to you. It's n
o o
n a n.
O'Noonan.
Yeah, the paper I'm referring to I think
is the presence and significance of
foreign loan words in the Book of
Daniel. Riveting title, uh but very very
packed with good information.
Yeah, man. It's the it's the kind of
like autistic [__] I love.
All that stuff I love to read.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, me too. Me too. I do that stuff
all the time.
All right, man. I'll I'll check that
out, man. I'll check that out. Uh if
you're if you're
uh
like maybe like a couple of weeks like
after I've read the stuff like cuz I
like if you're having a live I I'd like
love to talk to you.
Oh, sure.
>> Yeah, I try to
I try to go live on my channel on
Thursdays. So I'm not competing with
Avery here. So if you want to call in
then uh not like we can set like if you
would call back in again and Avery just
text me and if I'm free I'll just jump
in or something. Yep. All right, bro.
Yeah, no problem. Thanks.
Cool. Cool.
>> [sighs]
>> Um so far so that so that's it so for
now. We'll see you until next time.
For me?
Yeah.
Yeah, Logic God bless you.
But I if there's just uh one more thing
I could ask, this one's like a a lighter
question, but it's like about the law.
I And again, like I know
uh again, I was really feeling guilty
about some of the things I said about
Paul.
But,
it does seem like
like what's the basis for abolishing the
law?
Like for like saying circumcision isn't
necessary or like
you know, uh the the like the allowing
people to eat food that's
dedicated to idols when the Old
Testament says don't do that. Like why
does he allow these things?
Um
>> Like I'm not trying to insult him. I'm
just I'm just like wanting to understand
why he allows things that were forbidden
before.
So, When Jesus said like I'm not I'm not
coming to like abolish the law.
Yeah, so John Walton talks about this is
that the the Torah was meant to be a
light for the nations that Israel
surrounded. What could they do to
project God's goodness and light to
those nations? And so certain rituals
were put in place, certain food
restrictions were put in place to
represent order, to represent uh these
things that they would have understood.
But, when the gospel went to go out to
all the nations,
you that that is that that's going to
change things because like if you're
witnessing to people in like Britannia
or in like, you know, Africa, like
they're going to be like, "Well, what do
these food laws apply? Well, that
doesn't represent goodness to us. So,
why would these apply here?" So, when it
goes out of that cultural milieu where
it was situated in Canaan, then it's
like, "Okay, well, these certain things
were for a specific time, for specific
purposes." And now And Paul understands
the scriptures well. So, he's saying,
"Now that it's expanding out to the
whole world, what matters is the
spiritual aspects,
uh the the aspects of the new covenant
to represent God's goodness to the whole
world. And so, that's what's sort of
going on with there.
All right, that that makes sense cuz
like Paul Paul's trying to spread it as
far as possible. Exactly.
Yeah, just uh
kind of like what he just mentioned,
type and shadow. That's a key thing to
remember. Like if you look at Hebrews
10, number of other places like in
Colossians, you'll see this concept
that's given of type and shadow and or
shadow and substance sometimes it's
said. So, the shadow is sort of the
thing before the thing, but it's a sign
of the thing that's going to be coming.
And so, when the actual substance of the
shadow is there, you don't look to the
shadow anymore. That's the analogy
actually that Paul himself gives. And
remember, he himself was
a came out of a rabbinic school. And
then, another one is the idea of the law
is a is a tutor to teach us to Christ.
Uh that's one way. And so, the idea is
what part of what the law does is show
us our sinfulness. Shows us our our lack
of ability to do it on our own to point
us to Christ. Another term sometimes is
given as a guardian. So, until something
else happens, you have a guardian until
there's a proper age. Well, when you
have what needs to happen, which again
is Jesus, then you have it fulfilled.
But here's an interesting thing to
remember about these discussions.
Did Adam have the law of Moses?
Did Enoch have the law of Moses?
Do you see what I'm saying? Did Abraham
have the law of Moses? Did Isaac have
the law of Moses? Did Jacob have the law
of Moses? You go down the list. Did
Joseph have the law of Moses? The answer
is no to all those. And yet, God is
still dealing with men and women.
There are are things that he asks them
to do, tells them to do. And if you
notice, they're not always the same
things.
And so, what it means is each time you
have a covenant, a way that God is
dealing with man, there's essentially
terms that come with a covenant, what
we're supposed to do. So, for a long
time Israel was under the old covenant
and that included people who are united
with Israel's God by being united to
Israel, the strangers who had joined
among them and they would have to do
those things, like circumcision. But
now, that you have the way people get
linked up, for lack of better word, to
the one true God of the universe, it's
not by joining with a physical nation or
a physical people, it's by joining with
Christ or rather being joined to him.
So, it's a new covenant, which he says
before he dies, he says, "This is the
cup new covenant, my blood poured out
for many." And so, he's letting you know
we're entering into the new covenant.
So, the the under the big thing to know
there is what is the difference between
the old and the new covenant. And
one book I recommend on this is a book
called progressive covenantalism. I know
it's a big long title, but it shows the
way that the Old Testament laws are
fulfilled in Christ and what that means
for the believer going forward. Old
Testament Old Testament new covenant,
you want to kind of start to learn the
the levels of continuity and
discontinuity between each. So, it is
sort of a lifelong project of how to put
your Bible together. I mean, how does
the Old and New Testament fit together?
But the right answer is it's through
Jesus. So, picture an hourglass, sand on
top, then it gets thin in the middle,
that's Jesus. Everything else after that
is filtered through him on the bottom of
the of the hourglass as well, but Jesus
is that center point. And that's what
the message is again. In fact, last
thing on this, Jesus' message
himself is about that, right? He says,
"The law and the prophets spoke of me."
He says this a number of time, the best
example is on the road to Emmaus with
those disciples when he says that. And
then he says things like that again and
again and again. So, it's understanding
we are in a new covenant. So, those
things have been abolished and that word
is actually in Hebrews.
Uh get gets translated different ways,
but the idea of abolished or another
word like it. It is in Hebrews in
relationship to specific things of the
law and the big one there is the
priesthood. Jesus our high priest,
right? But yet he's not of Levi. Well,
how does that work if we're strictly
under Old Covenant regulations?
We're not. So, we are in a new covenant,
but here's the point of Hebrews. The new
covenant is superior. So, whenever you
have people who want to try to push you
back into the old, it's been a
temptation since day one. That's what
the whole book of Galatians is about.
Regulations is the antidote to people
trying to push the law on you when you
have Jesus.
All right, man. Like you guys, God bless
you. Thank you for this conversation. I
really appreciate it. God loves you. God
bless you and your family. Keep me in
your prayers cuz I I want to become a
Christian.
You know, keep me in your prayers.
And uh
But who Who said Someone said something?
Sorry, I'm just doing a bunch of stuff
around the house.
>> you? Yeah, sorry. I'll mute myself, but
God bless you. [laughter] God bless
Sorry, man. Yeah.
Yeah, man. And and Roger, keep doing
what you're doing. You're bringing many
people out of Islam
into, you know, you're doing the right
thing. You know, God bless you guys.
Thank you very much. And uh hopefully
maybe in a couple of weeks I'll see you
guys, but I appreciate everything you've
done for me, brothers. Thank you very
much. Thank you, Sully. Look, man. Next
Next time we talk, I'm I'm hoping to
hear an official testimony, man. We'll
see. I will
say I will say my Christian Shahada in
in in uh in Jesus' name, right?
>> Jesus' name. Amen.
All right, see you, bro. God bless you,
Sully. Peace. All right, man.